there's some people that actually
believe that the onset of a first
depressive episode and that can be very
reactive something happens in a person's
world
they have a breakup they um they lose
their job something goes wrong and they
have a depressive episode as a reaction
to that there's actually one hypothesis
out there the kindling hypothesis that
says that that first oppressive episode
almost sets up a kind of a
a sort of a
a reset of neurotransmitters that makes
a person more vulnerable to ongoing
depressive episodes that would happen
without a trigger as though that first
episode kind of booted the brain into
sort of depressions and option kind of a
place then the neurotransmitters came
along for the ride which is why those
first episodes of depression are so
important to prevent and why things like
stress management and all of those
issues become so important especially in
adolescence because that going into
early adulthood is when we often see
that first depressive episode